That's fine.
I'm not going
to hear about psychology as a career,
a career
for nine to five
job
where if someone else tells you what to
do,
and usually it's fairly similar to that
is that
someone else tells you what to do
because
if someone else is telling you what to
do,
then you don't have to figure it out.
And if you work from nine to five at
five,
you're done.
If you have a career,
then you're never doubt.
So one of the things that I want to give
some consideration to when you were
fighting for here is how we learn to
tolerate never being done.
I think I went to graduate school in
1985 and I think the first time I was
caught out
might be this year,
but maybe it happened five years ago
once or twice to talk to me
30 years to catch up.
So I was behind for 30 years.
And that's um,
it's hard on your nerves,
so you have to accustom yourself to the
fact of the matter how much you work,
you're not enough.
And maybe you're starting to accustom
yourself to that in the universe.
But the thing about university that's
different from the rest of your life is
that although you already are facing
facing problem with that,
there's way more to learn and you're
ever going to be able to manage the
won't be first and then you're
responsible to at the moment is
fundamentally apart from your parents to
some limited degree is yourself.
Whereas once you start developing your
career,
you're going to be responsible for a
larger and larger and larger number of
people.
And some of them will depend on you for
four actions that well if you're a
clinical psychologist sometimes that
their lives depend on,
so your responsibility level continues
to decline as far as I'm concerned.
That's a really good thing.
People and the fate,
that responsibilities of a burden,
but,
and I suppose that's true,
but what the realize is that human
beings are like sled dogs are pack mules
were not happy generally seeking and the
lettuce,
unless we're shouldering the burden of
carrying the load,
I guess as part of being a social
animal.
So it's actually good.
You have the opportunity to shoulder
responsibility because it helps you
tolerate and living with yourself.
You have to be worth something in order
to really
tolerate the conditions of your
existence.
And so you've got to pick up something
heavy and carry it because then that
helps you develop some respect for
yourself and also for the table and
that's a big deal that's worth more than
anything that you,
anything else that will possibly be able
to point.
Now,
how many of you are you in your first
year?
Put up your hand from seat because I
need to know what I'm talking second,
third and fourth year.
Most of you were in third and fourth
year are so,
so you're thinking pretty hard about
what to do so well we'll start with the
course supports your students for those
that you want to apply it in.
Graduate School,
which is of course I suppose what you're
going to do.
Most of you,
if you want to pursue psychology as a
career,
better have a's as if you don't have
aids.
It's going to be rough.
It might be rough even if you do have
a's,
but it's unbelievably competitive,
especially in clinical psychology and
it's increasingly the case.
And this isn't such good news for those
of you in your third and fourth and your
fifth admissions committees in
universities are starting to look before
your last two years.
They're really only supposed to look at
your last two years because everyone
knows that the students,
it's reasonable to allow incoming
university students or a year or two the
scream their heads on straight before
you start determining whether their
performance is actually an indication of
their ability.
So generally drives the committees are
only supposed to look at the last two
years,
but it's getting competitive enough so
that they're looking farther back.
Anyways,
clinical psychology requires aids.
Um,
and then of course all you have to take
your driving record exam.
Um,
there's two of them.
There's the standard grocery gripping
examiners,
the psychology specialty,
drag aggression.
Most many universities don't want
required a psychology graduate record
exam.
I would strongly remember,
I would strongly recommend that all of
you take it,
it's your friend.
If you're a psychology student from the
University of Toronto and have done
reasonably well,
the prob nick probability is high,
but just ace it because it tests
knowledge that you've acquired as a
psychology student.
Whereas the gre,
the general gre tests,
more general knowledge,
including mathematics or arithmetic and
mathematical knowledge,
and that's not as easy to acquire.
But about site students at ut asis
psychology garage was record exam fairly
frequently.
So even if the university or
universities that you were applying to
don't require it,
you might as well take it and send it to
them.
Because if you have a stellar 97th
percentile,
then you know why don't want to include
the information in your package.
So if you score less than 80th
percentile on the verbal portion of the
General Gre,
I would strongly recommend that you
don't consider a psychology as a career
because it's unbelievably writing
intensive.
And it'll go the into the variety into
the ground.
Some people are pretty smart
mathematically and analytically,
so when they write the gre,
they do well,
they do better on the nonverbal parts.
And I've had students like that who were
really powerful intellectually,
but more non verbally God,
deeper,
greatest statistics,
and they can be really good analytical
thinkers about the writing just killed
them.
You have to run all the time as an
academic psychologist and you have to be
very verbal as a clinical psychologist.
And so if you're not up and up,
I would say top 50 percentile of the
people who are taking the Gres,
it's going to be a real variety for you.
You should think about that very
seriously because it's the writing is
the most difficult part of psychology as
an academic career.
And if you're not a fluid writer,
you're going to have one miserable
prime.
You're going to drag your way through
graduate school and you're not going to
be productive because writing ability
actually determines research
productivity more than anything else.
And if you're not productive,
you won't do well on the job market.
And so it's to something else.
There's no sense sending yourself off
for,
you know,
a six year Brian and then a dismal
outcomes.
So students who aren't as,
who are more intellectually powerful on
the nonverbals sections of the gre are
often pretty good at designing
experiments and they can often learn how
to analyze the data too.
And that's great.
Let's pause his graduate students to
stumble this writing up the papers.
And so I often have students too who
baby,
you know,
completed 10 or 11 studies,
which is not planting to finish their
darker,
didn't publish,
you know,
uh,
several papers but they just cannot
break them up.
And so then they language because no one
else is going to do it.
So if you're,
if you're verbally oriented,
that's a good thing.
Don't be thinking that you get to pick
where you're going to graduate school
because you don't,
and if you think that you get to pick
where you're going to graduate school,
unless you're a straight 4.0 students
with 99% of the Uris,
then you're setting yourself up for
disappointment because it's so
competitive that what you do is you
apply to every bloody place.
Love half a chance of getting into
including prices.
But you think you'd ever go?
I think lake had,
for example,
has a clinical program now I've got
nothing against weight yet,
by the way.
And a small universities have real
advantages sometimes because you're,
you're less anonymous at small
universities,
but you might think,
oh,
I'd never go late as well.
And you might be also thinking then they
will never go to the clinical graduate
school because that could easily be the
only place that you'll get in.
So what you do,
especially if you want to go to clinical
graduate school,
is you apply every single place that you
can in Korea.
Whether you think you build,
they're not can always say no if they
accept you.
But if it's one,
you know,
maybe maybe it'll turn out at one place
accepts you and that's a place he didn't
think you want to go.
Well there's a big difference between
being in clinical graduates who are not
using it.
It's the difference between zero and
one.
And so if you go off to lakehead and you
come up with a clinical phd and you're a
clinical psychologist,
so who the hell cares if you have to
spend five years,
you know in somewhere that isn't a trend
in urban setting,
you're going to be sitting in a box most
of the time anyway.
It's made out of cinder blocks doing
your experiments and most of your life
fill fee,
the social life of graduate students
anyway,
so it's not like you're going to be
missing anything.
One of the things you might want to do
if you're fortunate enough to get
accepted and you're not sure where they
would want to go,
just to go talk to whoever's going to be
your supervisor because more than
anything else you ever do in your life.
I would say if you go to Raji school,
you're an apprentice to a supervisor,
you're not a member of it department.
So your relationship with your
supervisor basically determines whether
graduate school works for you or not.
So you want to find out ahead of the
time if possible,
whether the person who wants to work
with you as someone who then who is it,
who you're,
who you think you can get along with.
What they're working on is less critical
I think because it's not if you know
what you want to do research or you
might think you do but you don't know
enough to,
so I would also strongly suggest that
when you write your applications for
graduate school,
you make the person tell people who
you're writing to,
who you are,
but don't specify a research interest
too closely because hardly anyone is
doing half research.
And why give people an excuse not to
take you.
You're looking for an excuse not to take
you 81 so if I'm looking for graduate
students,
I have a staff of a hundred applications
or maybe 150 I get rid of 75 of those so
fast that they might've,
well,
might as well have not even apply.
They're just gone.
Usually what I do is I make a
spreadsheet.
I put in grades and the gre scores and I
called the lenders have breakfast and I
some across the rank order them,
I knock off the bar and everyone else
does that too.
Even though they might not do it in such
a
quantitative way,
they should because that's the most
efficient and accurate way of doing it.
But everyone else looks at that pile of
resumes.
It's more to do the same thing.
So,
so you're already 50% of the people who
applied,
they weren't going to get in it like
anyways,
that's already cop caught.
He don't want off of this type of
statement of interest.
It says,
well I just want to,
you know,
look at the left hemisphere where hey,
you have specialization for second
language learners who are children,
but there's probably one person in North
America studying.
And so anyone else who might be
interested in your application because
of your qualifications could still look
at that and say,
well he didn't want to work with me.
And then you're out deal.
You can say what you work on or be
interested in,
but what you should do.
And I'm not asking you to falsify your
letter if at 10 because that's foolish.
But what I would take you to consider is
that you don't know that much about
psychology and
why did you do it?
When did you specialize as a graduate
student is you started to go,
it's in a sexy,
narrow as you start off with without a
lot of knowledge about one specific
topic as you narrowed,
it comes a time when you start to
broaden out again cause you get into the
seal talking deeply enough.
So you started acting starting to tech,
you start to have to consider the
contextual issues that surround that
coffee.
So for example,
if you are a saint richards
neuroscience,
but you ended up studying language
development as well.
At some point you're going to run into
the brain,
right?
Because language development depends on,
so psychology and since it's an
amorphous feel and there's an entry
points,
all the entry points are narrow.
But once you pass through the narrow
your point,
you're in the field.
So it doesn't matter that much
specifically what you'd be doing your
work on for your master's degree in
particular,
cause you don't do enough to specify
that at all.
And you'll be,
if you're fortunate,
your supervisor will basically tell him
what to do for your master's degree.
It always takes a year,
right?
Well it takes you two months just to
clue in when you first started a new
program and then you're already a
quarter of the way through the first
semester somebody hurting us.
That pretty much has to hand you a
project and you have to walk through it.
And so what it's about is important as
the fact that it's at hand and you've
done it.
I'm not saying this well,
but what you're interested in doesn't
matter.
It matters an awful lot,
but you don't want to prematurely and
narrow.
We specify you're building an interest
when what you're relying on is
information that's not all that reliable
and you're not an expert enough in
psychology where it needs to make that
have determined the decision about what
it is that you're going to study.
I didn't have enough 70 all sorts of
things I never thought I would study.
Things I didn't think were were studying
that turned out to be wrong.
We were plenty.
We're studying an intern up to the
necessary.
So um,
learn your bloody stats.
You should be a wizard with spss or some
others,
some of the computer program.
From an economic perspective,
there's nothing that you'll learn as a
psychology graduate students that's more
valuable than statistics.
If you use statistics,
the all sorts of things open up to you
don't know the experimental work and you
have to be a statistical expert really
could be a good scientist.
But Cross disciplinary collaboration
because most other social sciences stoke
half here,
this statistical expertise that
psychologists do consulting for
businesses.
There's,
there's all sorts of value in doing
statistics and understanding.
So for those of you who are in your
earlier years,
don't shy away from statistics,
especially the more practical end of it,
which would be the computer,
you know,
the pc or Mac programs.
I wouldn't say pc,
generally pc programs that enable you to
do statistics.
You should get good at that part in
someone who will teach you how to do
statistics.
Statistics is actually extremely
interesting once you start looking at
your own data because it's a lot more
and I mean that technically at all.
If you pull a slot machines arm,
there isn't much of a chance that you're
going to get a good outcome.
But for some channels and so it's
exciting.
A off is variable reinforcement and
research is like that and statistics are
exactly like that because maybe you've
spent six months putting together a data
set and you are raising the variables to
ask ess statistical machine so to speak
and you both handle it.
Now you just learned ways or you wasted
your drive for six months or you hit the
Jackpot.
So it's actually pretty exciting.
It's different when you're doing in
class or working on someone else's data
set because what they know you care,
but when you've got,
when you've got something in the game,
it's an entirely different process.
Should also tell you that statistics is
not arithmetic and it's not.
Mathematics is more like surgery and
it's a moral endeavor,
which is funny.
You wouldn't think that was one
statistic,
but it is a moral endeavor because there
aren't any real rules for doing.
A data is an amorphous and vague entity
and there might be information in it and
your job is to carve off the garbage and
to keep down,
to pull up the information that
reporters doesn't require.
The automatic application of a set of
statistical rules that just won't work
at all.
Your job is to figure out where the
truth is embedded in this messy thing
that you just produced,
this vertical study because most
studies,
they're complete disasters you've never
been or how to do that,
right until you've already done it and
so there are,
there are mass and whether or not you're
going to be able to pull something on
that mastic constitutes genuine
information.
Depends on how skillful you aren't using
the statistical tools and how carefully
you make your decisions ethically while
you were,
you're attacking the data.
Because for example,
there would be a pretty damn highly
motivated to come out with something
where p is less than 0.05 right?
Because otherwise it's not technically
publishable even though that's a rather
foolish criteria.
But that's still the point.
So if you put six months in the study
and you know you have to decide where
the outliers are and where the masses
who to throw out concentrate on,
there's the little career day,
we'll let the doctor,
your mind is going to be pushing pretty
hard in the direction of money with the
data in a way it makes what you want to
come out of it.
And you can bet that 40% of published
studies,
cited studies at least are absolutely no
utility whatsoever because the way they
were produced was biased by the fact
that the person growth of wanting to
publish the study.
And so that's a terrible thing because
it works the whole feel,
but it's even worse if you have to be
the person that's doing it because you
know,
fool yourself yourself into discovering
something that isn't there,
then you will convince yourself that it
is there.
Then just spend the next 15 years
chasing something that doesn't exist and
trying to prove to yourself and others
that it's real.
And that accounts for a big chunk of
what passes for psychology and
researches.
It's a standard in some ways and the
journals are changing the way they
accept papers right now because this
happens so frequently.
So one of the way things want to do if
you want to be paid an academic
psychologist,
but you want to be a scientist as a
careers,
you benefit your,
your,
you have to decide what it is that
you're doing.
And what I'm saying that you might be
doing is building a career which is a
social enterprise.
It's a proud name,
dominance hierarchy into for us and it,
it means that what you're focusing on is
climbing up a private,
a dominance hierarchy.
That's not the same thing,
is trying to pursue truth insights.
Those are completely different things.
If you pursue the truth in science,
you might also January and career.
If you generate a career,
you might also pursue truth and science,
but the probability is relatively low.
Now,
I would suggest that you pursue truth in
science.
And the reason for that is,
well,
first of all,
you won't get corrupt and second,
if you corrupt other people,
but perhaps more importantly,
from an existential perspective,
20 years down the road,
you won't look back at your life and be
disgusted by the whole thing and sinful
and not even to teach or to talk to
students or to be a good graduate
advisor because you're sick and tired of
the whole business.
So,
and that's exactly what happens to
people who could do things in a crop.
Man,
I think it's cynical.
And why did it go?
It shouldn't be cynical because they're
the sorts of people that you should be
cynical about.
So the other thing you should decide to,
if you want to pursue experimental
psychology as a career,
duly you actually care about scientific
truth.
Does that matter to you?
If the answer is no,
I would say go into business.
There's nothing wrong with going into
business.
I've got in,
this is important.
It's not easy,
but if you want,
if what you're after is this sort of
status that comes along with a business
career,
don't get hit.
Again,
going to have to be,
yeah,
you might as well just go into business
and do that.
You're not going to make much money as
it as an experimental psychologist.
So if you're after status and the sort
of status that comes along business and
it sort of productivity and social
relations that come along with fitness,
just go into business.
Don't,
don't do it.
Don't sidetrack yourself off into
something that's in a sense of more in
pursuit.
So,
okay,
so do your stats and get good at it.
And you know,
you might be resentful about having to
do it because a lot of people who are
sort of oriented towards the humanistic
psychology are pretty irritated folks,
statistics.
So I was certainly one of those people
because it didn't come naturally.
But if you can't have to get a tutor and
hit age and take more stats courses,
then you think you need because you'll
need them.
So,
and if you go onto graduate school and
you're sort of crippled in terms of your
ability to approach statistics,
you'll pay the price for it.
We'll get an understanding of papers,
we'll go do your own analysis.
Stab me.
Okay.
So I everywhere,
I mean,
you might say,
well,
I can't afford to apply everywhere
because each application is under $50
riding on this.
What is it now?
$100 $150 that's silly.
That's not a cost.
It's an investment.
And you need to distinguish between
costs and investments.
And if you get in,
what are you thinking?
What are you think of?
Experiment a phd is worth,
let's say you get an afternoon last
work.
Yes.
Yeah.
Cool.
Is it 100,000 for females?
The doors?
What do you think his work?
Pardon?
Ballpark.
Saturday.
Okay.
That's good for how many years
maybe?
Yeah.
Okay,
so that's hundred freaking on the doors,
right?
What's your tension word?
Were other two and you were undressed to
be,
you underestimate the salary in the
latter part of their career.
So it was probably 7 million doors.
Okay,
so now you know what you're,
you're in that,
you get that APP,
you get that acceptance letter in the
mail,
it's worth 7 million doors if you play
it right.
And if you're a clinical psychologist is
probably worth twice that.
So you're after a $14 million price,
you ask,
well why is it so competitive while now?
You know?
That's why it's so competitive.
Lots of people would like to have $14
million.
So it's hard to get it.
So,
so then if you're applying and it's $100
$150 let's say you've got a one in 10
chance or one in 20 chance of getting in
and any given school.
So let's see,
what would you pay for a one in 20
chance of $14 million?
How would you calculate that?
Right?
14 million divided by 20 so you pay
about $700,000 something like that.
So you pay $700,000 not a hundred so
let's have that because you were
skeptical about your chances of winning.
Fine.
So then you paid $350,000 well don't
Balk at 200 it's a bargain.
And don't get too irritated about the
application process.
It's annoying.
They're trying to annoy you because if
you get annoyed and quit,
then they won't have to look.
You've got an application and that's the
end of you.
So take a big amount of time,
do your application because they're
really important and do lots of many is
the APP.
If you can afford,
you think about points,
bdos throw some applications down there.
That's especially true if you're a hot
student and you're a hot student.
If you've got a basically an a average
and the gre of 90 percentile or above,
people will be interested in you.
And that means it might get a
scholarship to the American school or do
you want to pay the tuition?
So,
and that might especially be the case.
You don't.
Maybe you want me to go back with you at
Harvard,
although little at night,
but there's lots of state schools down
there that are excellent.
The big research schools,
and maybe they'll paint it from down and
study.
So not only do you get your crap,
70 million or $14 million,
but someone will give you some money to
help you get it.
So that's a pretty good deal.
So don't lays out all over the bloody
applications.
It's really important.
All right,
so now local back to more general things
for a minute.
So now we might want to talk about what
makes people successful.
Okay.
And do you want also think about what
success means,
right?
And what success means.
I can give you a couple of rules of
thumb of both.
Dot.
I mean,
the first thing is if you want to be
successful,
let's,
let's put that,
let's use a different phrase.
So we could say,
well,
let's say you want to have a good life.
And I don't mean good in that it's happy
and easy or any of those things I need
sorta hood classic.
If you want to have a platonic need.
Good life.
Okay,
so how would one go about doing that?
Well,
the first thing I would say is do what
other people do unless you have a really
good reason not to.
So what people,
what human beings do,
they have a good life.
They have friends,
they have a circle of friends,
some of whom they can talk to.
Careful.
You help the important things.
So you need that.
People have an intimate relationship
with someone that is stable across time.
Why?
Well without that you're kind of chaotic
and loss and plus new when we have half
your brain because people are pair
bonding animals and we're kind of
communicative and if you have a partner
that you can trust who's got your back
that you can talk to and planning with,
then you're twice as wise as the person
that you're competing because it's just
like,
you know,
why is there sexual reproduction instead
of coal,
coal,
reproduction.
Why is that
you,
you guys are taking biology courses.
It's pretty fundamental question.
What's the answer to that?
Variations.
That was part of it though,
right?
Yeah.
I mean,
as a unit,
you called yourself first of all the
parasites to get again in no time flat.
But apart from that,
do you have a bunch of straight on to
weaknesses and they're kind of random
and then you'll pair up with someone
that has to match the strengths and
weaknesses.
And Eric,
you ran it and hopefully when you pair
up,
most of the places you're weak,
that person will be strong and vice
versa.
So that makes you a much more,
I'm more,
it's more properly solidified unit.
Sometimes a weakness is a match and
that's where you will fight nonstop.
And so you know,
we'll have to be a promise.
You're a lot better off with somebody.
And that's especially true if you also
want to have children.
And if you're foolish enough to have
children,
I don't know you guys,
most of the women in your most,
you'd be under 25 so there's probably a
fair number of people who think you're
not going to have children.
Must have plenty of,
I'll dispense with that foolish idea
right now because all that means is that
you just have your,
you'd be more,
that's one thing.
It means,
and second it means you don't know who
the hell you are because my experience
is feeding it virtually.
I think this is virtually without
exception.
Every woman I'd ever met,
whether they thought they wanted
children at the age of 21 or 22 or 23 or
24 if they were basically mentally
healthy,
they were desperate for children by the
time you were 30 and that kicks in about
28 and so expect it because it's going
to happen and you might think,
well,
I know it's,
it's not going to happen to me.
Well,
you can take that if you want,
but I'm basically what I'm telling you.
One,
my work,
I've done a lot of work with really high
achieving.
Most of these were female partners.
Senior partners is being offered and
being a senior partner of a big law
firm.
That's as hard as being a successful
clinical psychologist and you have to be
at the top of your class as an
undergraduate.
Then you have to get into a really good
law school and you have to be really
good at that law school and you have to
go off an article and you have to be
kept as an article in student and
generally you're not because the loss
big law firms,
you know,
pulling Arctic new students,
working with deaf and throw away all the
ones that don't make it,
so you make it well then you get to the
associate and then they'll get it to
bolster those two and then if you're
really good at it,
you'll be a senior partner and so that's
tough and mode and make your email and
you've done that.
Your blood will committed to your
career.
It doesn't matter.
By the time you hit 28 to 30 and you're
working 70 hours a week,
you're going to be thinking,
what the hell am I working?
70 hours a week four which is reviewed
by the way.
Good question and you're,
your attention is going to turn happy
children as it should and the way you
solve that.
If you're a female and you want a career
as a,
you have a partner who's got clue and
can provide some support and be you
outsource most of your domestic,
most of the domestic responsibilities
that go along with the household.
Yap,
Yap Anatomy.
Maybe have to have a cook.
You don't do any housework.
She pay attention to your kids with a
little bit of time that you have and
that would work.
Daycare care doesn't work.
You're bloody law firm isn't going to
take care of your children that are not
going to set up the paid care in your
firm.
That does work anyways,
but a nanny will work.
And so you might as well be thinking
things along that line because if you
want to have a career and you're smart
and you're hardworking and you showed
how the career as you want to have
children,
then you have to set your life so that
you can do those two difficult things
without dragging yourself stark raving,
mad or exhausting yourself or destroying
your relationship.
And that's about the only way that I've
seen so far that it's possible to do
that.
Okay,
so anyone's back to the back to career.
so now we've already established that
what you're after is worth a lot and
it's hard to get and it's hard to get
cause it's worth a lot and there's lots
of people chasing it.
Now the question is,
what can you do to give yourself an
edge?
Okay,
well,
what makes skew good perception from a
career perspective?
Well,
one is I you,
well,
you're pretty much stuck with what
you've got.
You can maintain it by exercising.
It turns out physical exercise is the
best way you maintain your and thousands
across time.
It starts to plummet pretty
precipitously after your voting did 24
and it's downhill the 70 and then we'll
after that,
things get worse.
So you keep yourself in good physical
condition that's going to make a big
difference.
I would also say if you want to play a
sharp gauge,
so if you're going to be on the edge of
things competing with people who are in
say in the top 1% top,
you better get your drug and alcohol and
you send control because that compromise
you.
You better make sure that you're
sleeping as well regulated and you'd
better make sure that you eat proper.
And those are there.
They're not small and it's their big
things cause you do the mammary day.
And so I would say you can start to look
at yourself now get up at the same time
everyday.
Start learning how to do that.
I would say get up to eight or seven 30
because that's when civilized people get
up and the people you're competing with
from,
you're really good.
They're all already up at six and
they're working by seven and they'll
work you right into the ground because
the people who are at the top and their
discipline,
and that's basically what you're talking
about.
If you're talking about doing something
that requires phd level education as a
career,
they're not popping around.
Okay.
So here's the question.
Think about this for a minute.
So think about your typical day.
Now think about this.
How much time do you waste?
And so you've been defined based any way
you want the weight to define it.
But I would say time is wasted.
When is that what you plan to keep you?
Right?
You know what it feels like to waste
time.
You feel like a moron,
right?
It's,
I didn't know it was a feeling that
really for me it's like a feeling like
that needs to take a shower.
It's,
I deviated from the appropriate path.
I mean,
you know,
Youtube,
the hail,
some [inaudible].
That's not the good.
Okay,
so now you thought about that typical
day.
How much time do you waste?
All right,
so let's find out,
um,
how many people waste more than half an
hour?
All right.
Is there anybody here who thinks they
don't waste half an hour?
Okay.
And if you do take that,
please do tell you,
cause you know,
maybe you're efficient.
Some people learn to be efficient.
Okay.
How many ways?
Two O's.
All right.
How bout,
how bout three?
Okay,
how many think they waste less than
three hours?
Okay.
One person.
Okay,
I'll come back to you.
Four hours.
Five hours.
Jesus,
you better wake up people.
Let's say five hours.
I won't embarrass you further.
What's your time?
No Matt,
let's come on.
Let's make him money that's told to use
to,
to evaluate.
Value
your time.
No.
Why is that wrong?
That's minimum wage.
No,
no,
no.
We're going to have,
we're going to play a capitalist here.
It's normally valuable.
I'm not going to pay you again for the
amount of money to do it.
Okay,
so,
so we're just,
we're just talking about economic belt.
That's all she has to be quantified.
We're going to quantify,
okay.
It's not tended the port.
Why?
Because he have a future Janet quarters.
What you're worth.
If you're tired,
if what you do,
how is it contributing to who you're
going to be in the future.
So it's more than that.
How much is,
okay?
Well,
let's look into this way.
Let's say you managed your career goals
in his head,
you feeling then you're making the
amount of money you should be paying.
So we've got a whole,
I'm here a lot back in the seventy five
thousand seventy five thousand dollars a
year.
So that's about $6,000 a month or about
1500 bucks a week.
And so we'll assume 40 hours,
that's about $45 an hour.
Okay,
let's assume that you're worth 35 you
can,
if you're slow Haiti,
you're,
you're not worth that.
But,
but the time that you spend it now isn't
invested,
right?
So even though you might not be,
he paid for it this second,
your banking one in sports.
So we paid for later.
So you can't be fake and it's 10 bucks.
So we'll say we'll say 40 because it
makes the math easier.
So how much time you're wasting a day,
five hours fast switch partners for it.
200 times 5,000 multiply it by seven
because after all,
we're wasting time on the weekends too.
So that's 1400 week.
How many weeks in a month?
Four.
What's four times 1400
okay.
5,600 so we'll say hi,
this same argument,
5,000 a month.
How many months in a year
you're wasting $60,000 a year,
right?
So maybe you should stop doing that.
$60,000
and there are people that people,
they give me competing with,
they're going to be wasting my time.
Or maybe you're going to be wasting
$30,000 or 15,000 of it.
But if you're wasting five hours a day,
you better get your act together because
you're going to pay for that.
And the way is that foolish waste of
time.
Now Iq,
there isn't much you can do about it.
We already said that you could actually
saw us and maybe you can read and you
can read it as broadly as you possibly
can until you should read every day.
That would be helpful.
And maybe you should read nonfiction,
especially if you want to be a
scientist,
what maybe he couldn't work on to work
hard.
And one rule of thumb to that is how
much time you waste.
Now you can do a little more in depth
analysis and when you speak down,
because I could also ask him,
I assume he said,
come and see me and they say,
what else do you do it or you want the
Scorps?
If we said,
well how much are you working on it?
They said,
well,
I knew ivory six times today.
And I think that's what I asked.
I asked how much time you're spending
working on because first of all,
you should be in the library for six
times a day.
That's just insane.
I don't know anyone at all except for a
very small fraction of people who are
extremely disciplined,
well put together who could concentrate
on difficult material for six hours in a
row.
You're lucky if you can manage three
like real work.
So the first thing you do is half of
your time in the library and naming and
double your discipline.
So,
so let's say we could look at a typical
hour that you're working and I might
say,
well,
how hard are you working during that
hour?
You how hard you be working if someone
pulled it out with a gun and said,
look,
if you don't work as hard as you can
connect to around under to shoot,
and then you might think,
well,
I'm not talking about one 10th as hard
as I can [inaudible] actually that's a
moat,
right?
I bet you that's about right.
The reason I use that fingers,
because I figured out a long time ago
that if you have a given task to do and
you sit for five or 10 minutes and you
think Coppin,
I do,
this headline is faster.
You can almost always figuring out how
to do it 10 times faster and some kind
of better and can kind of staff strep.
And that's also something to really know
because what you'll find as you mature
in your career is that you'll be asked
to do way more than is humanly possible.
And the way that you learn how to do
that is you get way faster than you
think you could be.
And just using the 10 items,
Margaret Little fountains,
an excellent one,
you,
it's remarkable how much you can do in a
very short period of time if you set
yourself up with that expectation.
So then when you remember what you're
talking is worthwhile,
then you might think about it.
$40 it's an underestimated your time to
actually work.
One of them has to be physical.
You're young again.
So
every hour that you have now,
if you shape yourself,
pays off through the old course of your
life.
You know a lot of what I do now,
it wasn't a did when I was 20 but what
you do now that you're 23 has been
effecting when you're my age.
So your time is actually worth more,
even though you can't get any better,
can pay for [inaudible].
So,
so those might rethink what learning to
do is to figure out how to get
efficient.
And you've got to be ruthless with
yourself to be efficient and then to be
efficient.
Because if you were going to pursue a
career efficient,
people win and they don't just wait a
little bit.
I don't know.
You know,
you guys have probably learned that most
things in life are normally distributed,
right
height.
Well,
you should have learned that if you're a
psychology student and you haven't
learned that,
then there's really something wrong
because that's like the basic,
that's the basic premise of statistics.
So of most statistics anyways,
so all right,
so you know,
maybe the average span is five for 10
and then there's a standard deviation
around that.
If maybe,
I know it's probably something like six
inches and then 85% of men,
60 60%,
65% of men fall in that range.
Okay.
So and heights like that,
weights like that.
When intelligence is like that,
most things are distributed according to
the normal distribution,
but lifeboat comes,
they're distributed according to a frito
distribution
and that's a free of distribution.
So,
um,
anybody know how much money Bill Gates
House
about
or you don't get me out?
So how much money did the top 10 richest
man in the last half,
300 billion,
something like that.
So that's a thousand gallons for every
single person in the United States.
This is more than the average family
hasn't savings.
So the top 40 men in the United States
have more money than all the rest of the
Americans have put together and saying
it's okay.
So the talk hundred richest man in the
world have more money than the bar and
she would believe it,
right?
So this is a great distribution.
It see the same thing with creative
production.
So let's say you're looking at Ph d
students and you want to know how many
publications they have.
Well,
the media now,
there is one.
The medium is the number that most
people have for.
It's not the means,
it's if you cough up for typical phd
student,
do I have to call her and said
publications can say one.
I say,
well if you're not retired one cause one
us,
then it doesn't count.
It's more than a zero,
but it's only one more than zero.
Okay.
So then there's going to be the top 1%
of the students way the hell over here
and they're going to have 22% of the
time they graduate,
which is about as many as been typical
associate professor has that tenure and
north of the people you'll be competing
on the job market.
So they published the be in their phd
for five years.
You'll publish more papers a year and
have promote and there'll be higher.
And so just for the sake of comparison,
the typical professor at a top rate
research institution,
according to North America polishes,
it could be three to four papers a year.
So the graduate students that are hot
prospects on the job market,
and that makes it likely that you'll get
an academic job,
although not certain are oh,
producing technical associate and
assistant professors at universities.
And there's hardly any of these people
and all of the science is done by these
people,
sort of the rest of them,
they're just wanting to be,
so all the people who aren't waiting on
at that tail end,
they're just keeping the institutions
running.
So what's the typical profit margin for
a typical corporation year after year?
Awesome.
Well guess how much money do you get?
How much interest do you get when you
put your money in the bay?
Matt?
Do percentage.
Okay,
so obviously you've talked to you,
what happened even with the 2% and no
one would ever destined.
Well,
so it's gotta to be more than 2% okay,
well it's around five,
5%.
So I'm really efficient.
Company runs on a 5% margin.
That means it's been,
is 95% of its fine just exist.
Everything is that we'll stay stand
mobile phones just existed.
All of the power comes into how many of
you put yourself in the coffin?
I'll
let you guys sweat and go here.
Okay.
So if you want to put yourself up at
this end of the distribution,
you do it
well,
I can give you an example.
Differences in people's could.
Awesome.
Are you 65,000 pieces as far three 65
years.
Okay.
And the median number of pieces,
parts for people produces zero,
right?
So that's a huge difference.
But almost all of them.
Fields of creative production.
I'm like,
almost everyone does nothing.
And a few people do.
Okay,
so
Bach Js,
Bach,
he wrote so much music.
If you took all smeared districts and
you just copied the
40 years and he was actually writing the
music,
not just popping up so people can get
unbelievably productive and
they're the ones who have to stomach
premiers.
Hey,
so what do you need to do that wow
can do much about your intelligence,
but we can learn the word and work
matters.
Conscientiousness,
it's just a trade is a big predictor of
longterm life.
Success and conscientious people are
ordering,
which isn't quite as relevant and
industrious,
industrious people.
When they put their mind to something,
they do it.
There's no wasting time.
And the people I know who were really
successful,
and so they were up in the top one 10th
of 1% which is only 1000 break.
So you guys are already,
he's probably one in a hundred if you
look at your Iq and your work ethic.
So one in 10 of you is one in a thousand
or so.
People like that.
They don't waste any time.
And I really mean that.
Then they five minutes be productive,
we'll be more than five minutes.
And most people do that.
And that's not an exaggeration because
they've learned to be bloody
efficiently,
do not waste time.
So they,
how can I do things too fast?
And they think,
how can I do this one thing.
So it does five things,
similar pace.
And also I kill five birds with one
stone instead of two.
And that way they maximal use of their
current and they disciplined themselves
and also the big rock in a cost of
battle with themselves about doing what
they should be doing.
They just bloody well do it.
And that's why they can produce,
they can produce at these levels reading
almost beyond human imagination.
So discipline really matters.
So if you're wasting time and you want
to pursue a different,
most career,
better learn how to get that under
control.
The best way to do that,
as far as I can tell us,
can pick something that's difficult.
You know that,
that,
that you'd like to do.
It's difficult.
Something that's kind of beyond you and
do it.
Bang your head against him will probably
that a couple of years of like really
hard work to mold yourself into
something that is utterly useless.
And that's a,
there's a big payoff associated with
that and I think that's something you
can do merely by warrantying it and
attending to and that if you do that
well,
first of all,
you get disciplined and that's really
useful.
It's why it doesn't matter so much what
you studied when you first go to
graduate school.
What really matters is that you started
something and you really study at heart.
Now when I went to graduate school,
I went to Grad school and neal,
we had a great time.
I had a great social life.
We be spent a lot of time going into
restaurants and going to bars and play
softball in a blacks.
But all the people I went to graduate
school with,
they worked like 10 hours a day and they
work like mad dogs.
And so that was fine.
When we're done their 10 hours,
then they can go off and have fun with
it.
There was no lock in about during the
work period and whether they were hung
over or not,
they go out and they enjoy their work.
And so that's what you have learned to
do and it makes your life more enjoyable
and entertaining,
not less.
I mean,
if you really want to waste five hours a
day,
I just wanted to 30 or wasting time.
If you live 90 years,
he wasted 30 years and if you waste 30
years you'd be,
and you wonder why you are attending
Edwards slash come on.
That's pretty easy to figure out if you
always 30 years,
you know?
And why should because you're just
wasting your time.
So it's best to really learn how to stop
doing that.
It'd be a terrible battle,
especially for those of you crossing,
you lost.
People are like,
you really have to rewire it yourself
and get that under control.
So if you want to be successful at a
high competition career and that's what
happened.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm going to start from it and ask them
questions and then I'll tell you a
little bit about what options you have.
If you choose psychology psychology's a
career,
what sort of things laying themselves
open to so,
so if you have any questions,
now's the time to as a pass from
extracurricular activities per se,
something outside of the career will
help you get into Grad school there.
No
for the Gres that slipped past.
The rest of this law mean if you hit c.
The thing is it's a multiple threshold
cutoff system.
So first of all,
you have to get aids.
If you don't,
you're out.
Then if you have a's,
you have to have certain gre lows and if
you don't,
you're out give you have certain grades
and certain gre was Dan.
You're in vantage random factors that
determine whether or not you're going to
get shows,
which is partly why you want to maximize
your probability of success by applying
to many any place.
Because let's say that you're a
threshold student.
Okay,
I'm going to look over your application.
Well,
what's going to determine when the right
data do I need us to eat?
Number one,
do you want to have to find it?
Do you have funding if you can get shirt
or,
or um,
MRC funding as a graduate student,
that helps a lot.
And if you're above threshold,
can you sort of act two actual and then
you got funding,
it's really easy for a professor and
say,
yeah,
you're not gonna eat up granite
resources.
So that's really helpful.
So you can apply for Grad school,
you have to still have the same level of
attainment.
Some extra curricular activities can
help with that you have or don't have
experience and you can write at a decent
research proposal that increase the
probability that you can get a
fellowship.
So laboratory experience and upstairs
lobby sterns also helps when you get to
Grad School,
cause you know what the hell is her
doing it.
You can get a jump on it,
but as long as you help them get in
much.
If I'm looking at two students who
basically cross threshold the say way
and one of them has extra lab experience
and maybe know some computer program,
you'd have some useful skills or it's
good statistically,
well men are all certainly prefer that.
But I won't even see the applications
unless those first two things are matt
and I promptly.
And not even deciding that.
Because usually what happens when you
apply is said there's a committee of
administrators that that was the first
pass and they don't even let you through
the your application through the door to
see the professors unless you meet the
minimum criteria.
So you know,
students desperate to give the extra
experience that we get into graduate
schools,
like a publication you couldn't help but
they're hard to get.
So if you do a like an honors research
project for example,
and it works,
you can write it up,
but almost no one does that because by
the time you're down,
you're down project and you've written
up your thesis,
you're only one 10th the way to having
it published.
And that's something else to think about
too.
If you want to be an academic cycle,
everything ever do will be rejected.
And not just the middle name,
either your work for something once for
six months we'll write your first
research paper and you set it up,
maybe not doing a very good journal and
you'll get free reduced back.
And they'll say,
this is the stupidest thing I've ever
seen and you might as well quit.
You know,
and that's,
and you'll get those letters throughout
her whole career and you'll say,
well this doesn't suck as much as it
could.
So to really work hard on it and use
this part of yeah and he would dress
these 30 concerns,
then we'll be willing to look at it
again.
But don't get your hopes up.
And that's when you go have,
you know,
a pint at the local bar because that's
the best news you're going to hit this
month.
So that's another thing to think about
too,
when you're,
when you're thinking about whether this
tourney careers for you,
because if you're rather high,
you needed the motion,
you're going to get punched in the
stomach a lot.
And you've got to ask yourself whether
or not you can learn to tolerate that.
It's just,
it's just a function of the,
of the business because it's hard to get
published,
you know,
the rejection rate to do the
journalist's 95 to 99% which is worse
than your application.
You know,
your chances of getting accepted to
graduate school.
So just looking for reasons not to
promise your damn paper.
And it can be,
because there's a mistaken,
I might give you guys,
it's too good,
you don't want,
and it scares people and there were
political reasons or whatever,
but there's a lot of rejection and
that's true for most of,
so you have to get used to that.
But in academia,
I think in some ways it's works because
you're always trying to publish in.
The answer is always,
we don't want your stupid paper.
We've got $100 ones.
So I guess you could use
research and teaching,
um,
uh,
want to widen.
The psychologist might choose to work
faster rather than full time.
Well,
okay,
well,
so one of the answers to that is why you
would ever want to be a professor.
Okay?
So here's why you might want to be
professor.
One of the things you might watch at
home yourself want to see when you're
talking with other people does your,
is your tendency to turn the
conversation to ideas.
That means you're open.
That's a trait.
Openness.
If you tend to turn the conversation to
ideas,
then you're yearning.
You're already,
you're
old.
That that's a good reason to be a
professor.
You don't know if your mom can you talk
to your friends and want you use most of
the time to talk about people are
meaning what he did last night here.
Those are fine.
Those are cross probably needs more than
you're extroverted or maybe you talk
about relationships and that means more
than that.
You were agreeable.
That's not really the kind of
temperament that is suited for an
intellectual pursuit because it's about
ideas fundamentally.
And then you also have to ask some,
what would you like to teach?
And teaching is teaching is brutal for
people who don't want light.
I mean,
you know,
you have professors like this,
a standing in front of the board,
they look down,
they mumble,
you're so bloody terrified at the
students.
They won't even look at them.
And everyone there is like checking
facebook.
It's all off.
So you know,
if you're,
if you don't like to engage in audience,
you're going to spend the most
exhausting part of your career teaching
because teaching,
teaching writing is very exhausting.
So there's three clinical work,
but right up there it was teaching
because I lectures of performance,
it takes a tremendous amount of energy
and who has to do with my role pins and
it's boring.
But otherwise it's like spontaneous jazz
for 90 minutes.
It's very tiring.
And when I teach three courses in the
spring,
I'm just flooded by mark and I got a lot
of energy.
So you,
you also have to decide if you want that
and then you'd have to just start.
Do you like mentoring students?
Graduate Students.
So I read it,
I got training,
I read it like I need a second.
I really liked mentoring graduate
students.
So it would be university professors.
Perfect for me.
I got used to being rejected.
The paper's being rejected.
I learned how to deal with that in about
three or four years.
He used to just piss me off.
I'd be naturally three months after or
you don't have to get the envelope.
I open it cause he know what it says.
It says up here,
but you're learning off.
Take that personally because it's not a
person and just hate everybody.
So if you learn to tolerate,
that's good.
Now you ask me why he would be a
clinical psychologist as well as the
professor.
That depends to some degree on what kind
of breadth of experience you were in
corn towards.
So
okay.
For me,
life is better if I'm doing a lot of
different things.
And so being a clinician,
I do,
I'm a clinician,
I do consulting with businesses.
I'm a professor and I run a little
testing company that evaluates
employees.
I have other,
I am not been jobs.
I think I have seven jobs.
That's what I figured at one point it
fluctuates between five and seven.
And the reason I do that because I
learned how to do flat out all the time,
it turns out I'm kind of wired for that.
So it's better for me.
That's better.
Um,
I'm loved doing clinical work.
It's sometimes people wonder too how you
can do it because you say more people
bring their problems to you all the
time.
Right.
But it like that because social work is
like that,
I think.
I think you're insane to be a social
worker if they do with thinking about
all the jobs that we'll just hammer you
to death over a five year period that
I'm teaching junior high school kids.
But see,
the thing about being a clinical
psychologist is the people who come to
do you have problems.
But they don't want to happen.
That's why they're coming to see it
when,
so what you're doing isn't dealing with
people who have promised.
You're dealing with people who want you
to get rid of their problems.
And so the trajectory is up hill and it
doesn't really matter how bad the curves
situation because if there's hope in the
future,
right,
because you're oriented toward the
future.
And so if you're working with your
clients and they want to have better
lives and you're helping them do that,
that's
it's a fine thing to do.
It's a great thing to be able to do
pursue the professorships instead of
full time clinician work because grab
her,
secure them that way.
It depends on the Grad program.
So there's two kinds of,
there's actually three kinds of clinical
graduate programs,
the graduate programs that are
characteristic of large research
institutions.
So say like Miguel and Miguel is mostly
a scientific institute institution with
a side Bar of clinical training.
And most research institutions are like
that.
And so most APA approved,
that's how it used to be.
Anyways,
APA approved.
American psychological association group
of programs tend to be research oriented
and they provide technical training.
So what they expect of you if you're a
student,
there has to be a scientist and to be
trained as a clinician.
Now also Seidi programs,
they're more common in the U s they'll
charge about $40,000 a year annual
training basically just as a clinician.
And then there are clinical programs
that are doing major research
institutions but are still stealing
public universities where most of the
emphasis is on clinical training and
classes on experimental work.
And they're usually not designed to Iran
on geared out producing academics who
could trade clinical psychologists,
which is what the big research
universities are for.
And yeah,
often when you go there,
we deal,
if you were a successful clinical
student,
he became a professor.
It was the unsuccessful clinic as
students who became a clinical
psychologist and you know,
you could say,
well that's because that was all they
can do.
Now.
That's a cynical way of looking at it.
In some ways it's true because to be a
professor,
a research institute like the Ot and the
clinical psychologist,
you have to be able to be a scientist
and,
and to do everything that's associated
with that.
So it's,
so it's,
it's a good option if you can pull it
off because you have all the stability
that he was alone with my in there in
university plus you have old
undergraduates and you know,
if you'd like them to graduates,
if you don't like undergraduates here,
you don't like people,
you know,
cause I mean undergraduate,
they're all shiny and clean and you
know,
they're all happy about their futures
and they're all probably going to be
reasonably successful.
It cannot be able to undergraduates,
you might as well go big old crime until
you,
because that's about as good as it gets
among human beings,
you know?
So anyway,
so if you're a professor,
you get to stay in the happy meal.
You and then,
you know,
I do my clinical work in my consulting
work as well.
So it's sort of like the best of both
worlds.
But there's a lot of,
there's a lot of preparation that goes
into doing all those things.
So for example,
you have to do,
I think I had been 2000 hours of
supervised practice when I came back to
Ontario after I was in Massachusetts,
even though I was licensed in
Massachusetts.
So there's,
if it takes quite a bit of work to keep
your,
cause just after you get your clinical
phd,
you,
you don't have a psychologist yet,
you have to do another 2000 hours of
supervised practice.
And to do that as well as to do what you
need to do in order to pursue an
academic career means,
you know,
you're,
you better be efficient.
So other questions?
Yup.
Is that a good play everyone?
Basically.
Um,
I've heard from a lot of people that you
should look for supervisors who are
working on areas that Uri and the cat
straight a's in 98% do whatever you
want.
If you don't apply everywhere.
And I would say even if you do apply
everywhere,
can almost say no.
You know what a delightful deal you
applied 40 places,
let's say,
or 30 places for it realistically.
And four people give you an offer and
you fly out there and they try to tell
you how wonderful you are and try to get
you to come in.
You get to say no to three of them and
pick the best one that's deal.
So that's what you want to set yourself
up.
So,
and you know if you,
if you really know what you want,
which is doubtful,
but maybe you do because sometimes
people do and you can specify who you'd
like to work with and they're interested
in.
You can target it that carefully.
Hey,
more power to you.
But that's very rare and for most people
is,
it's not a good strategy.
Look,
I've had lots of students
asking you about how to get into,
well let's say specifically clinicals,
graduate school,
and I say applied in lots of places.
Then they don't they,
why do you wait for places and their
threshold students and they don't get
here?
Well that's pretty rough.
You know,
they languished a year,
sometimes
two years as they try again.
Usually by the second year of not giving
him,
then they listen and apply.
It's 30 places and then they get it and
then they think juicing will fire them.
That the first year I would have been,
you know,
waiting at the local bar for two years
while I was trying to get into graduate
school.
So if if,
if you're 100% credible and you've got
the inside track,
you know there's normal rules don't
apply to you,
then that's fine.
But it's a numbers game.
And with most things that are low
profitability,
the way you maximize your chances of
success has to do with the law.
As you know,
if you have a one in 10 chance of
getting into somewhere and you apply to
20 places,
you know you're probably going to get
into to.
But if you play eight places,
you might get unlucky and get it.
They're not
so
not here,
not at St George Scarborough,
possibly they're working on,
but it's hard to set up a clinical
program.
You need a lot of medical faculty and
you need to be tied in with hospitals.
It's a multi year process.
So not this foreseeable future,
but your classical clinical program,
Ryerson hasn't been program.
No.
Is there a clinical program or noisy or
counseling
is plentiful.
Yeah.
Other questions?
Change from advising students for quite
a psychology,
it's easier to like if you're,
it's easier to get into graduate school
if it's not clinically.
How does that mean?
It's easy.
It's still hard,
but it's not an impossible like it is
with clinical.
Um,
the problem with that is that although
it's,
you know,
it's moderately difficult we'll say,
or even extremely difficult to get him
into an experimental program period.
The problem is is that when the
difficulty comes a little later,
the difficulty then becomes getting a
job because it's just as hard to get a
job as a social psychologist as it is to
get a job as any other,
I mean an academic job as any other
kinds of psychologists.
So the entry barrier for graduate school
is less at the entrance barrier into the
job market might even be higher.
So and so what you have to do is all
you're doing and group,
we've got it.
This is something to remember.
You are not going to graduate school for
the classes.
What do you want to do is barely packs
because otherwise you're working too
much on the classes because the classes
are useless there.
You're not going to learn a damn thing
and all they do is take you away from
what you should be doing.
And what you shouldn't be doing is
publishing papers cause that's all that
matters.
If you publish it on papers,
you'll get a job assuming that you know
you're not flawed in some remark,
obvious other way.
So,
so that you've got to remember that when
you go to graduate school.
So if you pass and graduate course you
get a name.
That's how graduate courses work.
Anything other than the name is that
failure.
So there's a bunch of complicated
reasons for that.
To pass the graduate class,
you'd have to do a decent job there.
They're easier than undergraduate costs,
but they don't matter.
You have to pass them because if you
don't know picky on the program,
but if you passed them,
it's irrelevant.
No one cares.
No one's ever going to look at your
planning graduate transcript for grades
except for maybe the grant.
You know the,
the fellowship granting agency,
so that's the money exception,
but if you pass the course,
you get an a anyways.
The reason you get a's if you passed the
courses,
because if you don't get a,
let's say I give 30% of my graduate
students these,
then they don't get graduate fellowships
because the graduate fellowship programs
will only get a graduate fellowships to
students who have aids.
So the way the university is to to that
is you get a's if you pass,
otherwise you fail.
So you have to work hard enough to get
ready for the course to pass.
Have you done that?
Then you have to work really hard to get
your down publications zone because
that's,
that's what will be them,
how hot a prospect you are when you
graduate and you want to be in social
psychology.
Each year was going to be five or six
strategies in North America.
Everyone wants,
so there the guys on the tail here and
then there's everyone else and everyone
else has a hell of a time.
It was top five students or six
students.
They have their pick of jobs.
That's where you want to be.
And to do that you need to publish.
The bar keeps going up because he gets,
even though it's hard to publish because
people tell,
you know computers have made the process
more straightforward,
right?
It's the journals are right at your
fingertips.
You don't have to spend a day looking
for each journal like you did when I was
a graduate student and then the journal
wouldn't be there anyways cause you can
get them instantly and you can do your
stats on your lap car.
Whereas I had to use a mainframe in 1985
and I tell you manage for that nate name
for it.
And I used a computer,
you know anything about statistics.
The manual was as long as this table was
one book on metal rods,
that law,
so like to do an a Nova was a nightmare
having just done so.
So some of the barriers to publication
number of followup,
but the consequences of that as the talk
students published form says learning
easier.
You just,
you have to spend the exactly the same
amount of times you would have before
except now even though it's hard,
but you're going to,
you're going to need 10 to 12
publications and a couple of book
chapters.
Most of those should be first offer.
You should be the first offer on five or
six of those papers and two of them
should be in picture and then you're
set.
But I'll tell you,
hit that you better do you run it
because it's,
it's,
it's not yet by and the students and the
problem with graduate school,
and this is something else to understand
it,
people will leave you alone in Grad
school.
And what that means is you can float
around vacating for five years,
graduate with one publication and
disappeared.
So it's dangerous graduate schools
dangerous that way because no one would
be on your case to make sure that you're
one of the top students.
So you have lots of freedom,
but you are also ask yourself,
you know,
do you want for him and Ken and
tolerate.
So do you want,
well people float drift if they have too
much freedom,
can you tolerate the questionnaires?
Can you discipline yourself enough to be
successful without someone?
Basically,
you know,
I'm watching you a big hey you in the
back of the hip.
And,
and that's a tough question because
it's not easy to become that future
oriented and that discipline.
So,
so that's the social sector.
The other thing I also mentioned about
social psychologist,
learn of your psychometrics,
cause most of the social psychology is
nonsense.
And there's a reason for that.
The reason is is that social
psychologists don't do all this and that
very well and they're starting to clamp
down.
Like all the journalists have adopted
the new code of ethics for publications
and reasonably done it because so much
of what particular this polished and
social psychology is simply not true.
So learner,
psychometrics,
and third year statistics and that will
redo your website and social psych.
There's lots of things to be discovered
in social psychology,
but you have to be hard headed and not
eat after your career.
So
I don't necessarily make sense or
missions.
How many good,
what percentage of classes have you
taken in the last few that were good?
Um,
maybe.
Okay,
so there you go.
It's worse in graduate school.
So 90% of the time in classes will be a
waste.
Do you want to learn to be a clinician?
You could start now.
We,
Carl Rogers,
we,
Abraham,
NASA,
we,
Carl Young reading Sigmund Freud.
If there's lots of great clinicians,
read them,
read them.
That'll help a lot
isn't that,
doesn't that mean that the system is
flawed?
Because yes,
all systems are flawed.
Most of them are like really flawed
systems are murderers.
If you're in a system and it's not
stopping you to death,
it's actually working.
Not too bad.
If you were supposed to be smart,
they are so wise.
One,
well,
I remember earlier in the lecture I
thought we talk to you about businesses
right?
I said,
business is run
on a 5% profit margin.
That means they spin it.
And that's an efficient business because
most businesses fail.
So really well run businesses produce 5%
profit year after year.
That means they spend 95% of their time
just existed.
And that's how systems work.
System Spin,
good system spend.
Only 95% of their time existed.
Bad system spend about 125% of their
time existed,
which means that not only do they not
produce anything of any value,
a sock resources from other things that
are producing things about.
And so really look,
it's really important.
I know you're skeptical about this,
but that's because you don't know what
you're talking about and you should
listen to me.
Most systems don't work and a lot of
them are murderers.
And so if you go off to graduate school,
it's not appointing hard cause you're
not this.
No you're not.
Yeah.
Well
that's what you,
okay.
Another question.
What would you recommend to take the
gre?
Most people usually take it say in the
summer before they start two o'clock and
that's probably vote right because I
wouldn't push it too close to when you
applaud because it's just the
application process is stressful and you
probably would want to clutter that was
up much.
I would also say
people do a lot of study for the gre.
It's north at all.
Do you want like the one thing you can
study for is the psychology of Uri and
the best way to do now sprawling
breeding introductory textbook or two.
But I wouldn't kill yourself spending
for the dra because it's not going to
help that much.
So part of it because it's like the
vocabulary that said
if build up your vocabulary over rated
to 25,000 hours of studying,
add another hundred hours for that
strong.
So
during the summer,
maybe early fall and then you probably
have to apply from November to January.
So anyways,
back to your question.
If you want to,
what do you have to do with the
university?
And this is what you have to do.
Graduate School as well is what the
institution does.
Is it opens up the space of identity and
the identity is you're a graduate
student.
Okay,
what does that mean?
Well,
it means any number of things.
It means you can language for five years
if you want.
But what it does mean is now you have a
stamp of approval on your forehead.
And so you sit around and read and learn
things and you don't have to worry about
whether or not you're useful because
everyone has said by all of the possible
measurement you appear to be useful.
So that means you can get to have the
luxury and educating yourself.
Now you can go off to the institution
and 90% of the courses won't be
worthwhile just like they are hammering
institution.
But some of them will be really
worthwhile.
And so your job is to discriminate
between the things that are worthwhile.
I'm the thing is the dark and to really
focus on where you can get educated and
there's lots of places to get educated.
So,
for example,
you'll have your placements and you'll
have clients and you'll learn I,
that's an opportunity right there to
learn because that would be the real
thing.
And you will need people who know what
they're talking about and you want to
stick to them like glue because they'll
teach you fixed.
But,
and it's okay that systems don't work
very well because they have to spend
most of their time just existed because
they're complicated things,
you know?
So
the reason I use the business example is
because businesses pay a big price for
inefficiency.
They just do was dive into the ground
and disappeared.
And so if even a business can only
manage 5% genuine productivity,
that keeps you a rule of thumb against
what she should judge institutions in
general,
it's hard to make something work.
And when you look around the world,
most countries don't work.
Most governmental systems don't work and
a lot of them get so out of control that
they killed him.
So what you hope for you hope you can
get into somewhere that has possibility,
opens up a space for you to do what you
can do.
If you're disciplined and ready to go up
and that's good enough.
And so the classes,
moderate classes,
they're not going to be worthwhile.
That's okay.
You put in as much effort as you need
you to pass them and you pay attention
to the things outside of that where
you're actually learning.
Awesome.
Well it depends on the institution that
you go to.
Like if you go into a psy d program,
which is just professional training,
they won't care if you published.
They're not trying to produce people who
are scientists.
The idea with the ADA programs is that
you cannot be a good clinician unless
you're a scientist and there's some real
truth and that's what the issue is
really hurt people.
Thank you.
Didn't mess up someone's memory.
No trouble.
If you're a foolish clinician,
you can cause a lot of misery and grief
because people especially confused in
vain people,
they'll open themselves up to you and
you can that and whatever.
Oh Kevin,
biases and lack of clarity you bring to
the situation has every possibility of
making things worse for them.
So,
so the big research institutions,
they want to train the thing
critically and
as a critical thinker is someone who's
good at getting rid of what isn't
necessary and keeping what is,
you know,
often when you think of critical
thinking,
you think of criticizing things.
You know,
this isn't good at that.
If that isn't the point,
the point is to say,
well that's not as good as this,
so I'll keep this is that it isn't as
good as this.
It's what you do when you the pain,
you get rid of what's not perfect,
keep the rest.
And that's what you have to do when you
go and get educated.
As a graduate student,
I would say if you want to be a
clinician re the great clinicians,
you'll learn more from them then then
then from anyone else except your
clients and with your clients.
Best thing to do with them is listened
to them.
And this is something that Carl Rogers,
that's one good reason to recall.
Well,
one thing that will Carl Rogers is he
really figured out her list and people
love to be listened to because most
people don't have anybody to talk to.
And because they don't have anybody to
talk to you,
they can't organize their brands.
Because the way people organize their
brains is by talking.
You say,
well,
I've got this problem and I don't know
what do about it.
So he said,
well,
what's,
what's the problem?
And they said,
oh,
it might be this,
it might be that you might be this,
maybe it's this reminds me of bath.
And it's like they're laying out the
situation on the table.
So we say,
okay,
we keep telling me less laying the whole
problem.
And then they're afraid of that because
they don't want to weigh in the whole
problem.
So you convinced them,
it's okay,
lay the whole problem,
we'll worry about sorting it afterwards.
So they made the whole problem and then
they look at it and you think,
oh,
well this isn't really the problem and
neither is this and this isn't the
problem with it.
Neither is that this is the parole.
And then it sorta cut down to size right
off the bat when you might say,
well,
you know,
what do you want to have happen?
So I'm not sure what I want to have
happen.
So they lay all that out and then they
push away what is it necessary.
Now they have the problem.
Now they'd have what they would like as
a solution.
And then you say,
okay,
well you know,
what steps can we institute little
stamps that you would actually do to
transform this problem,
you to this solution.
And that's very entertaining.
It's very useful for people.
And so one of the things you can do
right off the bat is a junior clinician
is listen to the person.
And if you don't understand what you're
saying,
just ask them.
Say,
no I don't.
I can get that.
So I'm clear.
Or maybe you say,
you just said that,
but 10 minutes ago you said this and
they seem to be opposite.
And I don't understand how those two
things can both be true.
And by doing it any walk them through
the process,
like your brain is organized at the
highest level linguistically.
And so if you walked through people
through a process of carefully
articulating their situation in order,
this is the brain and you can do that as
soon as a pretty junior clinicians as
long as you're,
as long as you're listening.
So yes.
What would she say?
That's a good question.
Um,
well I think there's,
there's two things you need to be
motivated.
Why do you need to have a clear
conception of what your life could be
like if it was really good.
So I can say if you,
and this is,
oh by the way,
here's an extra sentence you guys do.
If you do this,
we'll help you with what
you go to this website
and there's four exercises there.
They're writing exercises and if you do,
then I knew that I knew would be like
three times as efficient as you are now.
It's hard.
One exercise I'll ask you,
write an autobiography.
And the other is another exercise,
Alaska,
to do some personality analysis to
figure out what your faults are and how
you overcome them.
Another one,
the last few to figure out what your
virtues are,
how you can capitalize on them.
And then the last one asks you to figure
out,
here's wanted to ask you to do.
Basically it says,
here's,
you've got to get yourself in the right
state of mind.
So here's the state of mind.
Imagine that you were taking,
you were charged with taking care of
yourself.
Okay?
So now you're someone that you're
supposed to take care of.
I don't care what you think of yourself
because people are [inaudible],
you know you don't take care of himself
very well.
Put that aside.
We're going to assume you're going to
take care of yourself.
So you're going to figure out what would
be best for you,
not what you want or what would make you
happy or any of those things.
What would be best for him.
So you need to have a vision of that.
And you can ask yourself that three to
five years ago I had the best life I
could have.
What would that be?
Like?
Loneliness or exercise kind of steps you
through that and asks you to think about
people you admire or you think about
your friends and your family and your
career and the way you structured your
life day to day.
And you try to meditate on what that
would be like if it was off demised.
Okay.
And then,
and then the exercise steps you through
a process of clarifying that.
Okay,
so now that's your little vision of
habit.
Okay,
so now you've got that.
You know what your life could be like if
you were living at brock.
Okay,
now you need to do the opposite of that,
which this program,
why do we also asking everybody has a
sense of how they can fall apart.
All you do is look at how you already
have fallen apart and then you multiply
it out and you think of up with people
that you see on the street or that you
and you seen devastated marriages or who
have terrible relationships with your
family.
And you think,
okay,
what would my life be like if I really
let it fall apart?
And if you meditate on that property,
that should really scary and it's just
hearing the deeply.
So you should pick,
there's no way I'm doing that.
What ever happens,
I'm not giving that.
So then you've got your little happen
and you've got your little hat and you
know what the difference between,
and then you can start to conceive of
your day to day life in relationship to
those two things.
And you can decide which one you want.
Does he do that proper?
I get hit.
It's a DD process because if your life
really gets out of control,
not only you are you miserable beyond
comprehension but still perfectly
capable of making it worse,
you're a little source of community
pathobiology everywhere you go you make
it worse.
And that's how really that really is
hell.
And I would recommend that state.
I would recommend that you stay as far
away from here as you possibly can.
So you need to know those extremes cause
those are like the extremes of human
existence.
And you need to know that they exist and
what they are for you.
And then you can construe your existence
in relationship to those two things.
And that can help me feel motivated.
So
and in.
So it's good to do it as a meditative
process.
Making meditatively is different than
thinking in a directive way cause it's,
so here's a meditative exercises.
You can try this.
This is a very useful exercise.
So try this tomorrow morning.
If you do this regular,
you'll change your life and sees it.
It's a simple thing to do.
Technically sit on the edge of your bed
when you wake up and ask yourself like
you were asking
a friend,
not someone you knew well,
but some of you,
you have positive feelings towards you.
You'd like for things to go well for
this person.
Ask yourself what you could do to make
the day progressed in the best possible
manner.
So you ask yourself what you could do to
do that.
And then you ask yourself,
what do you actually would?
And you'll,
you'll get an answer and the answer will
drift up from the depths of your
unconscious.
You'll say,
well,
here's things that I've been avoided.
I should have,
you know,
chip away at those are the event.
And maybe I'd be this little thing
without getting hosanna full about it.
And then tonight my life would be one
10th of 1% better.
Just very much to go to admission for
someone who isn't very disciplined.
But one 10th of 1% is the law.
No one in a thousand days at one 10th of
1% if no compounding,
it's a hundred percent better.
So
those things can be motivated.
One of the things,
one of the things I've learned from my
own research,
because I do a lot of research and you
can tell Jerry,
is because it was very interested in why
people were motivated to do terrible
things to other b.
And the reason they're motivated to do
terrible things is because they left
their vice fall.
And your life is hard,
right?
If your wife is basically tragic in its
essence.
And so life is a difficult word.
And if you don't carry that burden
property,
it will make you resentful and that will
make you cruel.
And so if you don't want to be resentful
and cruel,
especially if you know what that means,
then you'll do what you can put yourself
together because you'd be a force for
good rather than evil.
That's a lot better.
It's a lot better.
There's almost no limit to how much
people can suffer studying to see,
which is also one of the reasons I
really like the clinical psychologist.
I mean being a clinical psychologist
keeps you very much in touch with the
actuality of people's lives and that's
very unbelievably useful and it's so
useful.
Like I spend 2025 hours a week every
week helping people walk through their
most difficult problems.
You can't imagine doing anything more
possibly useful for informing you will
come out to straighten out your own
life.
So
it's worth doing it seriously.
These are just oxes locally.
We've been doing research with the sweep
exercises.
We used the first,
the future offering on a group of
students have Miguel Hooper academically
struggling,
academic probation,
but there are still a smart,
right,
if you have to add behind the allocated
to the gill,
but they were failing.
So we had to go through this program.
We used to have balance control.
It was a perfect experimental design.
Um,
we raised their grade point average 25%
drop the drop out rate from 30% to zero.
It's a massive change.
Now we've been using the same program,
the future part of this on a bit at a
business school in,
in broader now we've used it on two
consecutive cohorts of 800 incoming
students and we draw their drop rate
from 50% to 30% and raised their grade
point average 25% and I mean I've used
the future authoring program regularly
on,
on people like know,
and also apply it to,
it'll change your life.
So people very seldom sit down.
First of all,
you have to think through who the hell
you are,
right?
Where you come from,
how did it shape you?
And that's really useful thing to do if
you're going to be a clinician,
it's like psych when else,
right?
It kind of gives you a sense of who you
are.
And then you also have to take some time
to think,
well what do you want from your life?
Like what sort of,
what sort of features do you want to be
cause human being.
It's an amazing thing.
You know,
like we can be just the most wretched of
creatures,
murderous and corrupt beyond belief.
But a person who has their act together
is,
I'm like a force of nature and that's a
lot better.
So you might think,
well you want to be a force of nature,
you know,
cause you got the opportunity.
You guys are smart,
you're young.
I imagine you're,
you're healthy.
And also you can at least manage
university.
It's like what the hell are you waiting
for?
Hammer yourself together and see what
you can do.
It's worth it.
Make your life way better.
I'm
imagine that would be better.
So if that's what you want,
no,
it's a good thing to do.
So that's,
that's,
I don't know any other way that people
would take it now.
Sorry.
I give a lot of agencies.
As you step through your life,
you will see that there are certain
things that sort of call out to you.
You don't have to grab your attention in
voluntarily,
and that's a very interesting thing
because people think that there are sort
of the masters of their own destiny.
You know that you own you.
People often will make that argument
about suicide.
For example,
it's my body.
I can do what I want with it.
It's like,
well,
no.
Neither of those things happen to be
true and if you act it out and you'll
pay for it,
but the rent,
there's reasons it's not true.
It's not.
Some arbitrary idea is that you're
governed by forces that you don't
understand,
knows of the forces the psychoanalysts
identify.
It's unconscious and unconscious forces
are the things that make you interested
in things because you can't control
that.
You know that if you're reading some
blood boring paper,
some other person might find that the
most thrilling thing in the world.
You can't even concentrate on it.
You'd rather do the dishes or you're
thinking about the girlfriend you hadn't
grade age or or something,
your mind wanders,
he can't focus on this.
You say,
well I have to focus on because there's
a testimonial.
So like your unconscious mind,
he doesn't care.
It's like,
no,
we'll go back into the carpenter or or
clean out underneath cleaning the dust
bunnies out from underneath the bed,
anything but read this paper and then
there'll be another paper that's twice
as difficult and you're compelled by it.
We'll just stick to it like glue and if
you'll remember it right away and you
think,
oh,
why is that?
Why can,
why is the one thing so easy for you to
get other things so difficult and even
worst whitehead in choose.
That's a strange thing because you
think,
well if you were in control you just
say,
well I'm going to be interested in this
paper and well good luck with that.
And so it is new.
Decided what we were interested with
that.
Then you go to ask yourself,
what the hell is it?
And when you start asking yourself that
question,
that's when you start to become a
clinical psychologist because that's a
hell of a question.
So anyways,
in terms of motivation,
one of the things you can learn is to
how is,
how to follow those things that compel
you.
And you have to be careful when you're
doing that because you also have to,
you have to balance that with the
certain degree of honesty because if
you're dishonest and deceitful video,
corrupt the workings of your neural
mechanisms and then the light would be
shining from places you don't want it to
shrink from.
So if you're going to pursue the things
that compel you,
which you can do,
which I think is a very good thing to
do,
that's a quest by the way.
You also have to straight yourself only
ethically because otherwise you will end
up taking some,
some bad terms and you can get
ridiculously motivated if you do that
because you'll end up living in a world
where everything is so interesting to
you all the time that you can hardly
stand and know
that's a good place to be.
So,
um,
I was just wondering.
No,
just some degree on what you do with it,
but I think it's a good idea actually.
You know,
and if you could,
if you could make use of the time and so
you have to decide is do you have
something to do with during that year is
productive and that will further your
development that will make you more
mature.
That would be the best thing.
Okay.
If
you want it to do,
no,
no you don't.
You remember it look like anybody you
want to work with is going to be
reasonably sensible because unless you
want to work with someone who isn't and
anybody who's reasonably since sensible
is going to think,
well you know,
this person's young,
they should go kick around a little bit.
You know,
maybe one of the problems with a place
like the University of Toronto for
example,
is it Lord for the students here like at
home for their home
undergraduate career.
It's like,
well that's not preparation for graduate
school.
You know?
So
if it will foster your independence and
make you more disciplined and broaden
your experience,
no one with any sense.
It's been a look on that as anything
positive.
Sorry,
say that again.
Well,
if you're going to go to medicine,
medical school,
you've probably pursue a career in
psychiatry.
Yeah.
And the difference between a
psychiatrist and a psychologist is that,
well the psychiatrist is an MD
psychiatrist can and does prescribe
drugs.
And there's nothing wrong with that,
by the way,
if you're a clinical psychologist and
somebody comes to see you when they're
like suicidally depressed,
what do you tell them as well?
You know,
we're not gonna make a lot of progress
and you kind of risks in the next two
weeks.
So you might want to think about taking
some antidepressants so you've got no
energy.
Put your life back together.
All right?
You don't want to be
dogmatic about any of these things.
So,
so drug therapies could be extremely
useful.
But generally if you,
if you take the medical group,
you become a psychiatrist,
well you can't prescribe directly,
but that doesn't really matter because
you'll learn enough about
pharmacotherapy in graduate school.
So I've know what I need with my
clients.
I just write them a letter to take to
there.
Generally the GP,
so you'll know you'll,
you'll learn what the basic
antidepressants are.
Those will be drugs you use most often.
Do you recommend most often because are
they're blogging he affected or most
conditions that involve excess negative
emotion now and then somebody will need
an antibiotic.
If you're a clinical psychologist with a
private practice that won't happen very
often.
So,
um,
medical schools a long haul.
So if you're interested in primarily in
working with people in a problem solving
capacity,
it could be the clinical psychology is a
better choice.
But you know,
you might be medically oriented.
Lots of people are medically oriented
and if,
if,
if the more,
if the more physiological element of
care,
Pos q and medical schools a good option.
Some people do both.
I'm going to talk about that.
That's,
but you know,
some people do both.
It'd be focusing on,
you mean for first year of graduate
school?
First year undergraduate.
Well what you should really give it your
first year as an undergraduate because
you should,
you should take a wide variety of
courses.
You should sort of find out what you
might be interested in it and you should
learn to learn to work and learn to
socialize because those things are,
you know,
the things that make people successful.
So I talked about two of them,
right?
Intelligence,
conscientiousness,
that's discipline creativities and other
ones.
But that's pretty hard to develop if you
don't already have one.
But the fourth thing that makes people
successful across time is Bradford
social network.
And so learning to socialize and to
develop a large connection,
large social connection,
that's unbelievably useful.
So you should get good at those when
you're in your first year,
you know,
and that statue pretty.
So if you come out of your first year,
you're still in university,
you got,
you know,
five courses under your belt,
Doug decently,
you have a circle of friends.
He started sort of start to establish
what you might be interested in.
Good.
And I was successful.
What do you think is the time that you
bought to the site?
Well,
the first thing I would say is it's
always better to do something than
nothing.
So don't wait around.
And what I mean by that practically is
if you're not sure what to do,
taking casts and do that and do it hard.
And as you do it,
you'll learn what's good above what
isn't.
And then in somewhere down the road,
six months to,
and be in a better position to figure
out what you want.
If you keep doing that,
sooner or later you'll figure out
exactly what you want.
But don't wait around waiting is you
don't learn anything when you were
lingual way.
So it's better to go off and try things
and to try too hard because then you
actually inform yourself.
And other than that,
there's no real rule.
It takes people,
it takes people of varying amounts of
time to establish an identity.
If don't have a well capitalized on,
you have to be,
by the time you're 30 you're starting
to,
it started to not be good.
And if it's really not there were still
by 40
that's really not so good.
So if you're confused,
get some credentials,
you want to have something to show for
your effort.
But if you pay attention and you focus
and you work hard,
you'll figure it out.
But
wow,
I,
but I,
but as I said before,
the best thing to do to begin with this,
you want to see,
you may not know this,
but the schools that you attended before
you went to university,
they were establishing their basic
structure was established in the late 18
hundreds and they were originally set up
to teach the children and factory
workers to be factory workers,
their factories.
You can tell just by looking at them,
even this to some degree,
it's still the factory.
It's the wrong model.
Probably factories is you're not going
to work in a bloody factor.
You're going to have a career.
And to have occur,
you have to figure out who you want to
be.
And so one of the things you want to be
doing over the next while is getting,
this is why I have a liberal arts
education is so useful because a liberal
arts education helps teach you what a
person could be and that's not the same
as getting a job.
And the university is not for getting a
job universities for figuring out what
sort of person you could be.
And so it's also useful to take
philosophy courses and to take
literature courses and to broaden
yourself so that you get a a better idea
of what the difference is between a
great person and the and the trivial
person.
And then me.
And that's not a very modern idea
because we'd like to think that all
people are the same and that's that's if
all people aren't the same,
he must have just stopped doing what
you're doing right now because you're
the as the same as you're ever going to
get.
If there's differences in quality,
then you should infer what's high
quality and then you should also know
what that is.
And so if your first year you wouldn't
get helps to to do some thinking and to
be guided by people who the culture of
recognizes as great thinkers because
they've thought about what it means to
be human and why that matters.
And then you might as well aim as high
as you can.
Hae not be a good thing to start sorting
out the first couple of years
university.
So
graduate programs,
I'm not sure I should go straight or
right off for ask as well.
It doesn't matter.
Masters are useless.
I mean for,
for
most places,
for clinically,
most places you can't practice with the
master's degree anymore.
In most programs have the masters.
I think you could still practice in
Elbert radicle bet,
but I'm not even sure about that
anymore.
For an academic career generally maybe
depends on why you want to take the
extra education.
You know,
if you're going to go into business or
something like that,
a master's degree might help you.
But if you're after the academic career,
it's a phd is you want,
and then it probably doesn't matter
whether you take a program that has a
master's Mphd or just each,
yeah,
yeah.
Um,
what about,
well,
I'm less,
I'm less informed about those sorts of
status.
So I mean,
as long as you can practice with the
master's degree,
then that's no problem.
But if you know
that that's a different career path to
be not as sometimes put you in as a
school counselor or something like that,
and that's perfectly fine.
What the patient choice.
It's a,
I won't say in some ways it's a,
it's a more defined in less demanding
life and that can be,
that can be extremely useful.
You know,
what an academic career or something or
a career like that.
It's a very,
it's kind of all consuming and that
isn't necessarily for everyone.
It certainly isn't forever.
And it should.
And it should be for everyone.
You have to be compelled in that
direction.
It be the choice.
I know you'd have to be more specific in
the question.
I don't know exactly what you're asking.
Right.
The best of your best bet is to contact
the college and find out what their
registration.
Good luck with that because their
registration rules are pretty vague and
it's hard to pin down,
but that is what you should do to
protect yourself and you should get it
in writing because it's all on the phone
that that's nothing.
You need to get it and run it and I
can't really,
I can't really give you any more
specific information than that.
Yeah,
yeah.
I can't tell you a lot about that
because I looked beside the hold.
The whole side of the street is outside
of the academic street.
They're professional schools.
They're mostly set up in the US.
They take a large number of students
feeding the acceptance criteria of much
lower,
but the price you paid for that is the
incredibly high tuition.
It'll,
he'll walk up by $200,000 debt.
Now that might be okay.
You might get to pay that off because
you being included,
local mission can be relatively
lucrative.
Typical hourly.
The rate is maybe first beginner is
maybe to get your practice going and be
perhaps 102 hundred $25 an hour,
and then that can go all the way up to
the $8,300 an hour.
Oh Ho.
That's uncommon.
One 75 was probably more typical.
And so if you see six clients a day,
let's say five,
that's $1,000 a day.
So it's about $250,000 a year.
So you can pay off for $200,000 debt
pretty fast.
But you know,
if you,
if you set up a successful clinical
career afterwards and there is quite a
financial or a clinical psychologist,
there's no glut on the market,
although people have to pay you
privately or through the insurance
companies because it's not an old hip
service.
Yeah,
well there's only about 40 large
research institutions in North America.
You can find them on the web,
they're the ones you already may know
about.
And then there was a sprinkling of
smaller institutions and their emphasis
on research productivity is a lot less,
or they're not,
they're not as competitive.
So you could attend those places to get
a decent training as a scientific
thinker at the same time that you
acquire your clinic license.
It's perfectly reasonable thing to do.
So that's why at the beginning I said,
you know,
I brought them because there's a big
difference.
There's some difference between
universities and the differences on
trivial,
but there was a massive difference
between being at a university and not
meeting.
I wasn't at all.
So if you have the
privilege of being able to choose which
university you're going to go too well,
great.
But you don't want to sacrifice the
binary choice,
the pause,
the binary choice just to
fiddle around with the Diet.
Okay,
so I'm going to close,
I'm sorry,
I'm just going to get a very quick
overview.
So here's what you did do as a
psychologist,
you're that if you're an experimental
generally you're heading for an academic
career.
However,
there are opportunities and research
enterprises outside of that.
So in businesses for example,
also the activity market for a
psychologist is really opening up
because psychologists are increasingly
being hired at economics departments and
business.
And as a junior professor at a psych
department,
you start with the [inaudible] at the
business school.
Let's start with the selling of up to 50
so business schools are having
psychologists because they're figuring
out that we know what we're talking
about.
Whereas Business Phds and economists and
not,
not usually because their models of
human beings are wronged and they don't
know their statistics very well.
So anyways,
the athletic opportunities for
experiment with a phd or Spanish,
it's a good time to be a psychologist.
So it's relatively hard to get it.
And when you're in,
you better be productive because you
won't be a credible candidate if you're
not.
So you've got to get disciplined.
On the clinical side,
there's almost nothing more valuable
than a clinical degree because you can
work as a clinician,
can work in a hospital,
you can work in academia and you can
work as a consultant or you can do any
combination of those things.
So it's,
you have a vast range of possibilities
open up for you.
If you have a clinical phd,
it takes a long time.
It's a six year phd and the new few
years of training after that and it's
hard to get in and when you're in it's
competitive,
then you have to work,
but if you can pull it off,
it sets you up for a vast range of
possibilities in your future now and
then
to conclude that personally,
if you want to set yourself up for this
sort of thing,
learn not to waste time because that's
the one thing you can do that sort of
under your control that will make you
more competitive and start to take a
boat.
They hard about how you want your life
to be and how you don't want it to be
because that can increase your
motivation to do things properly.
So
all take,
I guess.
Then there's another question that you'd
like to think that then we should
probably stop.
So it was,
anybody have a question that hasn't been
your sds?
No,
it doesn't.
Here's what you have to realize.
It's not your suffering.
You have your own suffering.
Your client is entitled to,
their suffering is part of their like
adding your own misery for theirs is not
going to help them all doesn't muddle up
your thinking and it encroaches on their
territory.
You're not there to take over their
version.
You're here to help them attain clarity,
figure out how to lift properly.
And so it's your,
you have an ethical,
it's ethically required to stay detached
enough so that you're not damaged by the
encounter.
And you'll learn to do that.
Everybody motors to do that.
In graduate school,
you'd be surprised like,
cause it get,
it's a perfectly valid question and
everybody wonders,
but you learn how to do that and it's
still called Ollie.
Do you learn how it's the right thing to
do?
So
one more question.
Yes.
The question about,
you said some.
So,
um,
how do you know if they're doing that?
Because they
look at your last year,
this only started happening in the last
couple of years.
Like I had a student last year,
two years since she didn't get in
anywhere.
It was she found out that just because
they looked earlier,
she had a pretty bad two year or two
years.
Would you be relevant?
Hopefully she'll solve that by applying
to more places.
But
as the number of applications grow,
then the reason you know the methods by
which people will be dispensed with get
more general,
I don't think it's reasonable,
but that's irrelevant.
Reasonable has nothing to do with like
your best.
And it's just like I said this to apply
to more places
and if you don't check weight,
if you're a or a minus 80 80th
percentile junior reasonable bob,
you're recruiting a candidate,
you hit it hard enough,
you'll probably find a place to go.
Yeah.
In the last two years.
Yup.
So that's still all right.
So
[inaudible]
thank you.
On behalf of anyone
[inaudible] I said yes,
you may or may not know this,
but the faculty and the student faculty
ratio of university
campuses for
that is outrageous and you guys put up.
So one of the things you might consider
doing is not putting up some letters to
the dean about the fact that you're a
450 of you to be shocked.
Me Number
five gram.
Okay,
so 407,000 so you pay $3 million in
tuition for each professor.
Nam Salary,
50,000 got some
overhead is 300,000 you paid 10 times as
much as you should.
Her factory seller,
you're getting screwed and the reason
you're getting screwed as because he put
up and it's really not good because one
of the things that would help you
progress through your academic career as
a psychologist property is if you could
actually get access to a professor now
and then I'm talking about things.
So I would highly recommend it to do
this with the PSA.
Do something
about you're getting ripped off,
there's no excuse for hundreds of one is
appalling.
It's 51 is a decent 451 your subsidized
the whole bloody university and there's
no excuse for it.
And he like,
he doesn't bother me because I just
don't talk to students.
Right.
Because I have a certain amount of time
and I'll talk to as many students as I
can and pass that I didn't talk to
students cause I can't.
So it isn't bothering me except that
you what?
You should do something about it.
This is no excuse for it.
And unless you pushed on university,
they will know what I'm doing.
So when you're paying 3 million bucks
per professor just hired here,
we only know English professors,
but it's not good.
It's like it's the worst faculty,
the student to faculty ratio of any
department at the University of Toronto
by a huge margin and a bone psychology
departments across North America.
It's about the worst.
So
you should use
no one
else.
You're going to have a rough kind of
truck.
Does he downloaded design basically
going now,
have you talked to Shelly Carson.